les républicains prépare depuis
longtemps les élections législatives et
nous le faisons dans l'unité avec nos
amis de lui dit ici présent nous avons
engagé ce travail il y a maintenant près
de six mois pour préparer les
investitures l'equilibre de cette unité
quelle unité particulièrement solide et
partout dans les 577 circonscriptions
nos candidats d'union sont déjà à pied
d'oeuvre
mais nous jugeons cette élection est
essentielle parce qu'elle va être le
seul moment d'une véritable consultation
démocratique pour nos compatriotes
en effet la présidentielle s'est
déroulée chacun le sait dans des
conditions extravagantes et les français
ont été privés d'un débat démocratique
essentiel pour la vie démocratique de
notre pays
aujourd'hui dans nos institutions qui
sont celles d'un régime parlementaire
le débat politique des élections
législatives revêt toute son importance
car c'est bien de la majorité que les
ans que les français auront choisi
d'envoyer à l'assemblée nationale que
relèvera la politique qui sera conduite
dans les années à venir avec le
président de la république que les
français viennent d'élire et c'est pour
cette raison que ces élections sont un
temps de respiration démocratique
indispensable
en quelques instants vous donnera le
détail du déroulement de cette campagne
pour ce qui est des républicains notre
famille politique
ici au centre national dans les
fédérations partout en france est
mobilisée et le socle que constitue
l'union elle est rude et y alla proches
de ces législatives reste et je le dis
en responsabilité l'un des derniers
points constant et solide de la vie
politique française nous mesurons
l'importance de nos responsabilités nous
abordons cette campagne dans un esprit
d'ouverture sans sectarisme prêt à
travailler avec tout le monde mais nous
considérons qu'il y a d'abord le temps
du choix démocratique des français qui
va s'exprimer maintenant
lors de cette campagne puis du vote des
élections législatives je remercie